you haven't pinched anybody's monies
right i mean i get what you're saying
and and
you fulfilled whatever needed to be
fulfilled and the balance
is what i'm asking you about where did
it go what did charities commission do
because
uh i mean what role did you play later
so ever since they froze the money i've
always been cooperating with the charity
commission even after i left
i've always been cooperating with them
and
so not very recently a couple months ago
they asked me for permission
the remaining funds can be sent into a
reliable source to the rohingya refugees
and i gave you permission for that
so alhamdulillah i am happy to know that
the money for where it was intended to
go it has gone to that it has gone to
the
rohingya refugees all the remaining
that's what i wanted to know
because i mean people donated for
rohingya i just want to
myself and you're giving me this
opportunity to clarify things so i just
wanted to clarify with
you to say did that money actually go to
rohingyas now you're telling me that
the 68 you guys took it personally and
you fulfilled it and the rest of it
charities commission you were
cooperating with them and
they asked you if they could actually
give that money to other charities
how are you guys doing so we just see
this woman now
who has been trying to con the muslim
community into thinking that she's a
pious woman
moving the cop her and her husband
husband ex-husband hassan at the boy
the boy who has before that
you know trying to be a rocky you know
what i mean and then
amassing a lot of money going on the
hunt letting his wife go to the clubs
at night taking off her neck up
and grinding with other men
clubs this is the kind of level of
hypocrisy that these people are
operating on
us at the same time trying to be pretend
to be pious people
trying to pretend to be religious people
you know trying to con
us come on please and now you come in
and you're trying to uh
to pretend that you've er that now
you're gonna what
you want to come back on the public
scene become a public uh
figure again you're missing the
limelight are you
maybe you think we're going to trust you
going to forgive you
now if that's something that you cannot
recover from
or would you respect now we're not
saying you cannot be
yeah your repentance is not accepted
we're not in a position to say that
obviously if you've repented to allah
that's between you and him
but we are in a position to say that
we're not going to be taken for a ride
again
by you or your ex-husband or the
or or the other woman
who is also videoed going outside the
clubs
whilst her husband was with her
you know outside the club's enjoying
themselves
was those men were around her you know
eyeing her up
as you want to put it in that language
and maybe even doing more
was the day youth was watching on
the day with hassanet the boy
and now they've come she's trying to
come back
you know crocodile tears uh
this and that you know make
justifications
subhanallah we've come a long way
haven't we we have come a long ways the
muslim community we
are not to be tricked twice and this is
uh hadith
which i i'm now going to explain the
context of because this man
in a battle with the prophet muhammed
he basically the prophet was merciful of
him when he first caught him
and then he called him again and then
the prophet muhammad
is not to be bitten from the same hole
twice in other words now if i'm in the
sahara
in the desert and i see an individual if
i see a hole there
and a lizard comes out of it you know
what i mean
i put my hand out and then the lizard
bites my hand i'd be a fool
i'd be an absolute fool to put my hand
in the same place twice in the muslim
community
we will be absolute fools to be
exploited again
by giving these people's views or
following them on instagram
or indeed contributing to anything
they do or say which has any financial
kind of implications so with that
i say salaam alaikum and by the way
and this is yes something i want to tell
tell the boy that you're finished
and not only are you finished but you're
gonna stay being finished
don't try and make you don't try and
don't try and come back because no the
muslim community are not gonna
allow it